hi I'm Timmy the trashcan and I love
trash popcorn boxes and candy wrappers
they all taste so good instead of
throwing your trash on the floor won't
you please give it to me
thank you for considering your fellow
patrons all right we're in folks here at
the Safari Inn it is Halloween night
Burbank California just saw a maid
talking to two other people staying at
the inn and they were like listen this
woman open the door she goes listen you
got to clean this whole room when we
leave we're both very sick which means
that they're all [ __ ] junked up in
there they're vomiting all over the room
and then this poor maid is gonna have to
walk in and deal with this [ __ ] when
these people drag their carcasses out of
this place and you know that's gonna be
late check out you know they're not
rolling their asses down 11:00 a.m. or
noon somebody's gonna be banging on the
door 12:45 probably the cops we released
the video today where I played the
Epstein's temple it's got about a
hundred and ten thousand views on
Twitter in about five hours which is
really nothing and I fault the majority
of you for not retweeting it because
what the [ __ ] are you doing set up an
account and retweet it the [ __ ] that we
make is great it's very funny and it's
hard to make and then you see what gets
9 million views and it's like you know a
gang fight in a McDonald's which is good
I and I do enjoy those but you know I'm
not asking for 10 million views I'm
saying smash the retweet button on the
[ __ ] Epstein temple video I spent
money on that costume
Ben followed me around LA I dressed like
the [ __ ] temple from pedophile
okay everybody told us we couldn't film
even flappers comedy club which by the
way if you're ever in Burbank and you're
in need of water to survive I would
never walk into flappers comedy club for
any reason but certainly not during the
what is it called flappy hour yeah not
during flappy hour which is the open mic
they have there what is it daily Ben I
think so yeah every day they have an
open mic for divorced dads and assorted
Psychopaths in Los Angeles County that
make their way into flappers for flappy
hour okay and then they instructed us
that we weren't allowed to film there
Ben's filming me I paid [ __ ] $10 for
a redbull I don't even drink redbull a
friend of mine was with me and and $3
for a [ __ ] water three and change
so of course you leave the five so $15
to perform for it seven people at flappy
hour and then this woman walks out just
a bento you can't film I don't even own
my own set after $15 and having to sit
in a room with the stench of delusional
Psychopaths comedy for these peoples
like it's not even it doesn't even it's
not even a hobby put it that way it's
not even a hobby they put any work into
it's something that was like
court-ordered for a lot of the people at
the flappy hour they said hey instead of
shoving your wife how about you go and
get some of that energy out of the open
mic instead of pushing your wife in a
stairwell how about you go and tell a
few jokes work out your anger that way
[ __ ] psychopath in that place I
remember I perform there one time and I
ordered what did I order do you remember
what I ordered the hummus yeah I would
have liked hummus yeah and the waitress
goes I didn't know what and I ordered it
like an hour before I got up on stage
which they couldn't figure out
put the hummus in the [ __ ] I imagine
many of the employees run the phone with
their illegitimate children and couldn't
get the hummus in the ball so then the
woman came up to the answer is he goes
hey I was looking for you all over I
didn't know where you were with the
Amish I said I was on stage dummy I was
on the stage for an hour
earning my a hundred and sixty dollars
god that place makes my skin crawl
I'll probably have to delete this when
I'm there next month I want to clean I
will not delete this I don't care I will
burn that bridge [ __ ] it I hate Burbank
it's a big mall I'm just waiting for
these people to stumble out of their
room and just start projectile vomiting
the way she looked at the majors like
we're really sick
you're gonna have to just burn this room
when we leave
110 thousands of views listen I'm all
I'm saying is this the video quality is
great the editing is great the [ __ ]
thing is funny
celebrities are such [ __ ] other
comics are such [ __ ]
so many people just don't want to
retweet it because you know I know you
don't want absurd any boy you know god
forbid god forbid this jeopardizes your
chance of getting on Deal or No Deal and
I know that's what most of you people
are in this for and I don't even blame
you cuz there's no there there it's a
mirage nothing is real just got a few
checks from Deal or No Deal
I don't even know what that show is I'm
errantly youuuu go with the deal or not
my career is called No Deal it's a show
called No Deal it's been going on for a
decade so I don't know what I don't know
what that show is but I know that I'm
sure there's there's a lot of game show
host in this city and I'd love a game
show some
give me a game show I'll tone it down
for the game show and for everything but
for the time I'm on air we cannot get to
a family-friendly version of this for a
half hour to an hour think about a game
that I could get involved in you know is
this okay with the cars is it not no
it's fine it's fine
we're recording outside on the deck of
the Safari end yeah but is it okay yeah
it's fine there's some traffic but it'll
be good okay it's not a big deal you
know folks it's called background noise
they don't you know why don't you
appreciate a little bit of a you know
ambient noise in the background like the
sound of a soft summer rain instead
except these are cars that a fleeing the
fires you could hear their wheels
screeching as the terrain around them
burns and they're in the car with their
family they're thinking about what would
have happened if that that family had
just burned with that house and of
course it would have been sad but it
would have been a chance at rebirth my
father's wife almost died once from food
poisoning and my dad looked so
disappointed when he talked about the
fact that she was saved and I don't
think it's because he doesn't love her
but there's a chance at rebirth do you
understand that it's not that he didn't
love her it's that you know waking up
alone sometimes is what's needed after
you've been in a bed for what next to
somebody for a long time sometimes
waking up reaching for someone who isn't
there is the ticket that's at least what
his face said he was kind of very solemn
when he said that she was saying he said
we almost lost her and the way he said
it it was he was very like
matter-of-fact like we almost lost her
but that would have been it and I would
have had to move on but he's like you
know she was she was saved and you know
we're all we're all back together again
I'm just saying smash the retweet button
if you can folks not a big deal if you
can't I get it
many many of his jobs you know what I
get fired whatever Instagram is like
hiding us you can get to Isis you could
have gotten to beg daddy on Instagram
before you can find me he's now dead but
you could have got to him you could have
got to his IG live before you find
anything that I do because Instagram is
you know I you know we just had dinner
imperfect you know and then we said I
said to the waitress I go is your
bathrooms because yeah just take the key
and go around back what the [ __ ] are you
talking about take the key and go around
back so I could watch work at the
restaurant why is the bathroom locked is
it really I guess it really is
post-apocalyptic hellscape out there is
everybody given birth in the bathroom is
everybody shooting up in the bathroom at
Murray's Italian restaurant in Burbank
whatever it was called that you need to
have it locked up we need to use a key
to get in is it that bad out there when
you check into a hotel is it that bad
that you the key works for three seconds
in the elevator to get up to your room
before you you have to you have to hit
the sensor again it shuts off after like
a second who is getting on the elevator
in between 4 3 and 4 7 to murder you
apparently everybody there was problem
as I say that because none of these
corporations give a [ __ ] there was
probably like a slaughter in like a
Hyatt or something there was definitely
and it had it was a
big chain and somebody got in there and
just went crazy
somebody went in there and went you know
breakfast buffet it's not good today and
they went into the elevator and plunged
a steak knife into someone's throat and
then hi it was sued and now it's like
the NSA get into your room there's
ninety five sensors to get anywhere and
then the cards demagnetize you got to
keep going down to the front desk and go
if they don't work they don't work did
you keep on me your phone of your wallet
yes I did I did I didn't keep it in my
mouth I have to put it somewhere on my
person how about we invest money into
cards that don't demagnetize by the two
things everyone has to carry don't
keeping your credit cards don't keep it
near your phone should I put it in my
ass for the day what should I do with
the card I'm seriously asking can you
hold it and I'll pick it up at the front
desk before I go up how about you don't
even give it to me if it's gonna
demagnetize standing there in the
elevator waving it in front of the
sensor like a psychopath everybody gets
in the elevator nobody knows whose card
to use who's everybody's waving the
cards frantically at the sensor just
trying to get up to wash their ass it's
it's enough already let people get
killed if that's the other option
let's live with the [ __ ] chance that
someone's gonna get us there's nine
bolts on every door in a hotel like I
guess [ __ ] went down and I was not aware
of in a hotel I guess somebody who
walked into a Marriott and disembowel
the family and nobody I didn't realize
how [ __ ] crazy hotels are with
security you know I stayed in in
Clearwater Florida they gave me a
bracelet which was cool because it's a
resort they go here's a little bracelet
but again you gotta use the bracelet too
get from the pool to the beach to the
lobby like every layer of gate you got
to go through now because apparently
there's just a lot of people stealing
other people's vacations that's what you
have to believe there's people stealing
vacations they're showing up to the pool
and they're sitting there and they're
stealing the vacation that someone else
should be having I get it I get the you
need security but there's got to be a
happy medium between like no security
and and feeling like we're like in the
underground city under Washington DC
there's got to be you know a Holiday Inn
Express shouldn't feel like the
Illuminati bunker under the Denver
Airport is my point it two people just
walked by I really had enough we started
out we started filming at this hotel
this hotel by the way thinks it's the
[ __ ] because Apollo 13 filmed here in
Desperate Housewives and a true romance
so it's got a cool sign it looks like in
1950s 1960s real LA you know it's got
the outdoor pool and it's a real cool
motel the way it looks and the rooms are
fine but the attitude here is that you
know it's this legendary iconic place
which is fine to a degree it might be I
don't know I don't think it is but the
attitude here I did tweet iconic the
other day just Safari it is a joke
because it's like what do you say
Connick this they call it iconic [ __ ]
iconic about it that it was in coach
Carter [ __ ] are you talking about
it's an inn make the bed stop
everybody's acting like but he's act
like you know that we're all it's like
Hollywood royalty walking around here
it's an end we're all here because we're
[ __ ]
what are you talking about it's termites
in my apartments why I'm here just a
woman I read to the department from let
termites eat the house that's why I'm
here not cuz I want to see the room
where true romance was filmed so what
they do is they families come here and
they stay and then they take them in a
van every day that to Harry Potter world
or whatever god-awful nightmare the
Universal Studios has cooked up for the
American family you know to take their
minds off of God Only Knows whatever's
ailing them you know it's a nice little
family vacation you come here stayed to
safari in and you there's someone in a
van drives you to Harry Potter world I
don't know what that consists of I
imagine it's rides III I imagine it's
were you a big Harry Potter fan no I
liked Harry Potter I didn't my I didn't
read the books cuz I'm an adult I didn't
read the books but I saw some of the
films they probably show all of the
films they're fine you know but you know
my friend's wife went to Harry Potter
world with her friend this is something
adults do now without any shame is it go
to a theme park for kids and that's okay
listen hey I'm not here to judge anybody
this is what goes on this is a fan
pulling up right now there's a van
there's a Jurassic world van pulling in
right now they yelled at us for filming
I wonder if we can if we're allowed to
park I think we're allowed to podcast
wherever the [ __ ] we want
yeah I think so [ __ ] I'll start
screaming at these [ __ ] if they
try to stop us from podcasting I'll be
like [ __ ] I own my [ __ ] voice I'm
not gonna pay you money to speak into a
microphone
of course you gotta pay you gotta what's
a rental on this 10 grand a day to shoot
more probably yeah maybe even a little
more yeah we got stopped filming here we
tried we filmed in the grove and that
stopped filming there which is a shot
outdoor shopping center in LA we got
they stopped filming we got told to stop
filming it flappy our
yeah the Supreme Court let us film there
they would not let Ben walk into the
supreme store in West Hollywood they let
me walk in I appreciate that
just like Epstein's temple mm-hmm
Halloween one thing I will say in LA is
it people have really gone to some
trouble decorating their homes for
Halloween and I appreciate that
like that's a cool [ __ ] thing
Halloween's a cool holiday it's fun to
see people get into it we never really
decorated for it when I was a kid and
I'm sure you didn't because you came for
a very Christian do we even allowed to
celebrate it yeah yeah yeah okay but we
did not really decorate my mother had
Christmas decorations that she would put
up and they were dolls and many people
from Long Island from other places I
don't think it specific to Long Island
many people know there were these dolls
where they had they were holding a
candle and then the arm would like go
back and forth with the little candle in
it it was just like there are these
famous moving dolls that you put in your
window it's like a display for Christmas
my mother loved doing that it was a big
deal she did not like Halloween that
much she thought it was satanic she
thought everybody was poisoning kids
with the candy she thought you know so
she didn't really go out of her way to
sober them but it's nice to see people
in Burbank really getting into the
spirit here it's nice and it's you can
see the kids when they when they hit
like the kids that are a little older
are walking around and they're kind of
you feel the energy of like they're
trying to like break off from the path
they're trying to get into trouble
they're trying to learn you know they're
trying to figure out like what's the
next move I remember seventh grade or
eighth grade I was I went out with like
the kids in my grade that were you know
popular or cool or whatever you want to
say they were all throwing eggs at cars
and other people that's what you did in
eighth grade that was like a rite of
passage that's as you were growing up
that's what you did you you you would
throw eggs and shaving cream and you
would vandalize property that's what
happened
that's what Holly
was about in the suburbs if you were a
winner
you would go out and he would get into a
group of people and you would vandalize
people's homes and their cars and you
would throw exit kids and hopefully
those kids weren't bigger than you and
would come and beat the [ __ ] out of you
and every now and then you'd hear some
story about I don't know some kid who
swallowed an egg and died or you know
there's always a story well you didn't
hear about you know you know Jeannie's
son went out and he threw an egg and and
someone turned around and shot him in
the head you know there's always those
stories you can get an eggshell in your
eye you know you know and you listen I'm
sure kids got [ __ ] up there were
fights should happen we always went
around there's a huge mob of kids and
eighth grade I went out for like the
first time with those kids and it was
fun like we had fun and then I think I
had dinner with my dad after it like
9:30 or 10:00 it was like a late dinner
at the steak house you know in the in
the town I grew up Jimmy Hayes and we
sat there and I was covered in shaving
cream but I'd rubbed it all in I was
wearing all black because I was in an
toughie and I'm kidding but I was
dressed like I was in an thava fat
antiphon chubby ant if I ate great I
wasn't fat I was chopping mean ray we're
gonna do a sketch called fat aunt Eva or
auntie for however you pronounce it
where we were two guys dress in black
supposed to go to a protest but instead
we go to Arby's and we're just dressed
in black and we just don't ever make it
to the it's like a funny
just a funny idea you just never make it
never make it to the whatever why I'd
rally the fight just never get there we
just keep going to different restaurants
like stopping off to just get different
fast food items on the way to the rally
and we just do we just never get there
and at the end like a Tomi Lehren type
girl comes and just like like hits us
with the butt of a gun or something like
we get close enough to the actual rally
and then she just comes in and just
[ __ ] but I was dressed in all black
and I had rubbed the shaving cream in so
I but I just then I just smelled like
shaving cream so my dad's like what is
wrong what are you smell like we're at
the table with him and the owner of this
restaurant I was a guy I just wore some
Cologne and the owner of this
restaurants like yeah cuz you're trying
to [ __ ] those girls alright yeah I was
like well you know me [ __ ] them hoes
I didn't say that I was like well I just
smiled my dad was like that's what he's
doing just wearing Cologne
trying to [ __ ] members of the opposite
sex which was not the case we were just
trying to have some fun and throw some
eggs and vandalize people's property
that they had worked hard for it kind of
slowed Milan as I look back now I go you
know what listen an egg on your Buick
LeSabre isn't the worst thing that ever
happened here you're fine and then the
big thing was gang initiate everybody
was like Halloween is a big night for
gang initiation and it might be it
probably is I don't know but I remember
the the worry was the fear works
everybody loves like fear everyone loves
to be afraid of what's coming I do we
all do we all like it that's what we're
all role invested we love horror movies
we love like peeking behind the Pew know
the monster under the bed what's the
deal you know where's the bad stuff
where's the dark show we want to see it
we want to see how bad it really gets
out there we're into it it's it's we're
hardwired for whatever reason and and
and you know everyone thought it was
gang initiation Halloween night
you know our mothers along our mothers
would be like you know Halloween night
is the night where gangs will just pick
a few you boys and kill you to get into
the gang they'll come here they'll kill
you
so that they can join the gang and me
and my friends were just in you know
staring at our parents stoned be like
well thank you for letting us know like
trying to not try to not let let let you
know let it out that we were literally
starting to roll on acid you know thank
you
well I I bet we should just go down to
the basement now and stare at the
posters on the wall for an hour too and
think about what to do with this
information
gangs are coming from the city very
coded words alright so what you're
saying is people from the city are
coming here to our leafy suburb to kill
us
to prove a point well I bet we should
sit down in the basement and just relax
for a little while before we decide how
to proceed with our evening you know our
pupils with the size of golf balls just
we don't really know what to do with
this but thank you so much for this just
wanted to let you know be safe out there
be careful
gang initiation and listen I'm sure
somebody when I do something like this
you know without without without fail
someone on Instagram will share a story
with me about an actual gang initiation
that happened on on Halloween I am I'm
not saying that that isn't happening I'm
sure it is have you did you hear that
that it was the night for gang
initiation - I never heard that you
never heard no no yeah I heard that the
one about the car coming in the opposite
direction with its headlights off and if
you like flash it then it'll like turn
around and chase you down and kill you I
heard that might be a thing Halloween I
don't even know I think that's that's
like animals wives tell yeah okay I
don't think that's real yeah Ben Ben has
no idea what I'm talking about like did
you hear the one about gang initiation
use like no I heard the one about the
chupacabra I'm like oh no this is kind
of based in reality
then comes from just this is [ __ ]
wild
background of superstition and no I
heard that
heard the one about the black cat
crossing a path and I heard the one
about the vampire and the werewolf no no
no no no we're talking about gangs now
some of them listen maybe maybe it is
gang initiation what the [ __ ] do I know
I got a wedding coming up this weekend I
can't tell you who is because the person
is famous and it's very nice and then
they also said hi we're not doing any
social media this weekend because we
want to respect everyone's privacy and
it's like hey I'm like into getting
photos with famous people so how can we
respect your privacy but also respect my
need to get photos with people who are
doing [ __ ] better than me in the
business so I could put them up and give
people an idea that I'm on a path I'm
not really on how can all of our needs
be respected at once can we find a way
to bridge the gap between your need for
privacy and my need to look like things
are going better than they are how about
we meet in the middle could we meet in
the middle no social media well how
about this just tell everyone I was
there then I don't have to go those
social media I should have to go it's
crazy I mean I don't know I'm listen
it'll be a good time and of course I'm
kidding I'm always kidding I've never
meant anything I've ever said ever ever
ever ever especially anything would ever
have said anyone they're all jokes the
things that are not jokes are the things
that people universally accept his
truths we only know what they are after
they've been said hard to know what they
are before they've been said you know I
wish I I wish I was in a really I want
to I want to be at a Halloween party
right now in LA with like some people in
my little cool costume and I want them
to be taking photos and I want them to
but I don't want it to be comedians I
wanted to be like post Malone or hey I
want to be at a party with post Malone
okay or even Karl Malone what if is that
such a is that such an unreasonable
request I want to be at a party with
Billie Eilish I want to have a photo
with Billie
Eilish but instead I'm at the end list
of these junkies tell the maid that
she's gonna have a lot of work out of
her when they slither out of that room
you can always tell them people are on
drugs and are pretending to be sick it's
one of the funniest things ever I mean
it's not funny in the sense that they're
destroying their bodies and minds and
souls but what is funny about it is it's
so obvious to everyone else that they're
not really sick and that they're just
either withdrawing from drugs or they've
taken too many drugs and they don't have
enough drugs whatever the case is we're
very sick both of us we both caught it
from each other ah did you huh but um
but yeah I don't I I don't I don't
really uh I don't know I think the gang
initiation thing was probably a myth
there was a lot of myth making like you
know we did the patreon opposite where I
talked about you know the false memories
and all that stuff and the idea that
like a lot of them might have been
actually hinting at real abuse I'm not
saying that people don't falsely accused
people I'm not saying that recovered
memory I don't know anything I'm not a
doctor I'm not saying that that isn't a
type of science where it could produce
some results that you know are not
necessarily true and accurate and
verifiable I don't know I don't know but
there was a lot of myth making going on
when I grew up
and the myths usually had to deal with
people coming to kill you and here's
here's the thing some of them were like
some of them weren't now that we've
known about you know the human
trafficking and stuff kids were getting
kidnapped kids were getting snatched but
not nearly as often as it would seem and
on Long Island you had to see some of us
they were getting warned like some of us
we weren't getting snatched if we wanted
to
nobody was pulling up in a van and
grabbing us but like every day your
mother would be like just understand
that there's people out there that are
gonna kidnap you and [ __ ] you Oh God
it's like all right the thing is if we
were innocent kids it listen they
weren't wrong to warn us but what was
hilarious is that we were cocaine
addicts and stealing from them that was
funny
in hindsight that's what makes it funny
hmm not so much that they were that they
weren't really wrong but it was just
funny that we were like going and doing
blow in the projects and they were like
you're just good kids there's bad people
in the world I'm like we know we're them
we got a good eye there are all of our
friends you know all the yeah you know
the people selling coke to 14 year olds
those bad people yeah we know them
they're pretty funny they're actually a
good hang um but I'm sure that there's
not I'm sure that there is not the thing
with the wedding there's a lunch and
then the ceremony and then the dinner I
don't need to be there for the lunch and
then the dinner we don't no one's doing
that no one's doing it we go for one
meal it's not nine meals otherwise you
go there for the whole week and I can't
go there for the whole weekend you go
for the ceremony you do the meal I don't
even go to my best friend's wedding my
friend Joe got married and where I I had
a select I had a weekend I worked for
years to start headlining in clubs and I
uh if they if they let you get a shot to
headline it could be the only shot you
get that year or that 18-month period
you want to get in the rotation of these
clubs
so a lot of people that I really love
and care about I could not go to their
weddings because I work Friday Saturday
nights this is what I [ __ ] do I mean
and and and I and I worked for free for
many years to get to the point where I
could get paid to work on a Friday or
Saturday night so it's not that I don't
value people committing to each other or
the ceremony but what I can't do is give
up and now now I can do it easier than
that then I could then now I can move
things around more than I could have
that back then I was just getting on the
mat this was like my first chance a lot
of these clubs headlining and you know
people get married I would after bike I
can I really have to work you know I
mean that's a fact you know it's
literally a fact I enjoy weddings I have
had fun I've had good times at weddings
I'm trying to think of my favorite
wedding that I've been to maybe my
friend Joe and Alison who you Matt
mortgage people they had a lot they had
a lot of fun choose a very Long Island
wedding the Long Island wedding is
always a huge waste of money a Long
Island wedding is an $80,000 where you
take a handful of money and light it on
fire
in front of a roomful of people it's a
it's a 12-hour event where you save for
like two years and you live in a
basement and you you because your wife
wants to feel like a princess for nine
hours before she goes back and does
medical billing for nine years and gets
fat she wants to feel like a princess
for just a day before she goes back and
starts drinking [ __ ] french vanilla
coffee made out of the [ __ ] bottle
with her other friends and smoking
marlboro menthol lights outside of the
medical billing office in Coram but
before she commits herself to a lifetime
of that she wants to shove her rib ice
i stake feet into a few nice shoes put
on a nice but cheap looking but
expensive wedding gown because Long
Island loves spending a lot of money on
something that looks like you found it
and then shredding her stuff she's been
on keto for nine months she's lost six
pounds she doesn't know what keto is and
you and all your dirtbag friends get to
go do cocaine one more time and I mean
one more time that week at a strip club
the night before the week before before
the big day and then your father gives
you a fun talk you know before the
wedding he says some you know profound
grunt oh you're like thank you that's
you know thank you for that guidance and
then you go to a place like Jericho
Terrace or you go to a place like
Leonard's of Great Neck where they shot
a scene from The Sopranos you go to a
garish disgusting Long Island catering
hall that has some stupid name like
Chateaubriand and you go to this place
and it has a fountain and it looks like
a place where they have like like Little
League trophy night which they do and it
looks like a place where subprime
mortgage brokers learn how to rob you we
did and it looks like a place where they
have sales conferences you know big
titted blonde haired [ __ ] and goombah
greasy head pigs eat chicken front
chairs and figure out a way to snatch
your pension from you with with the
PowerPoint presentations because that's
what these places do during the day and
then on the weekends they all light
themselves up so that Nicole and Tommy
can finally tie the knot a match made in
heaven I met Nicole Lilly Flanagan's
when she lost her shoe she was vomiting
when I asked if she had too much to
drink she said no it's because I'm
actually pregnant but she was she was
enjoying herself having a few drinks I
fell in love immediately
the next day I took her to get an
abortion and a bacon egg and cheese and
we discussed how sometimes movies aren't
good over the next year we decided to
move in together because we could not
afford our apartments on our own moving
in together was a very big step for us
because we had both been evicted the
week before
Nicole supported my DJ business and I
supported her as a medical receptionist
she would make people radiology
appointments and I would show up in the
parking lot and we will get high during
lunch break we adopted a pit bull which
we cared for as best as we could we had
to give it to my father because it was
hard to afford all of the food and it
also bit one of the children on our
block in the face we should have trained
it better but this is life as my father
always said it's always something you
know then I finally got a job punching
tickets on the Long Island Rail Road I
gave them my name four years ago and
then finally they allowed me to take my
place my rightful place among the
legends that work in the most important
job in New York taking people from Long
Island into the city so that they can do
their jobs and watch Rangers games
Nicole also did very well
sadly the two kids that she were
watching for a year got hit by a car so
Nicole decided she was going back to
bartender our parents were so proud when
we finally got married I proposed at
Flanigan's and then we have our parents
told us that they would pay for our
ceremony and Chateaubriand Nicole I love
you I've always loved you what happened
your friend doesn't matter you know that
she's a skank [ __ ] and I know that
you've always loved me I can't wait to
have many children with you show them
how to play baseball and get drunk and
beat each other up I mean that's the
Long Island you know and she's like guy
thank you saw me I love you Tommy my
name is Nicole I feel very special today
because my friend Donatella is here with
me I know that you've had many struggles
over the past four years you were gone
for a period of time in and out of rehab
and jail I love you Donatella thank you
for being where is Donatella she's in
the bathroom all right I get when she
gets out til I tell her I love her Tommy
you're so beautiful inside and out you
are not only a person that I know but
you're someone that I really truly
understand the first time we saw movie
together Harry Potter I remember how we
said it was overrated and we didn't
really understand it and then you
explained to me that we had actually
seen the third every Potter we should
have saw the first two Harry Potter's
first then we went and saw the first two
Harry Potter's with each other and now
Harry Potter is the most favorite thing
we've ever seen ever because I you're my
magic baby
we don't have Dumbledore but we got each
other our honeymoon will be at Harry
Potter world and we will stay at the
Safari Inn where they will pick us up in
a van there will be a fat man on it roof
yelling you will say that you think you
know him and that you did cope with him
in your town and he's the comedian we
will then ask him for free tickets to
his show at The Comedy Store
so I just want to say Tommy I absolutely
love you I want to thank my mother my
mother you've at you're everything to me
you show me what it's like to be a bad
[ __ ] who drinks Long Island iced teas
who doesn't take any shared who shows up
for work when she wants who quit
cigarettes and yet still smokes who
knows how to carry herself in the
community as the woman you told me how
to be a woman mommy I'm gonna cry
I just love everybody so much thank you
for sharing a special day you know so I
get I love weddings I love them
Long Island weddings are the best
wedding because they're two people two
criminals two demons two monsters two
things that crawled out of a swamp of
coffee creamer and bacon egg and cheese
with ketchup and buffalo calamari and
beer farts in Long Island iced teas and
excuses and the dog ate my homework and
I failed out of Oneonta two absolute
pieces of the puzzle that unites and and
start the process of living a horrible
life and ruining this world just a
little bit just a little bit in the ways
that they can being a little rude or a
little dirtier they make the world a
little less understanding Oh enough I
had a real rally there but I mean though
there's nothing better than a Long
Island wedding it's something that's
great there's real characters there what
are those two people dressed up like Ben
I love like the adults that are dressed
up in the in - they're both Pikachu's
they're both Pikachu's they got those
costumes at [ __ ] CVS sad what were
some of your Halloween costumes I was a
pumpkin a skeleton
SuperMario I think that was the last
time I dressed up I was Super Mario a
little bit of a basic [ __ ] with the
costumes nothing wrong with that well
you at will you ever like wanted we ever
tried to be a scary thing
no I never did I wasn't into scary stuff
I was into like video games and stuff so
I just dressed up like Super Mario or I
think I did Yoshi oh I did Simba one
year
what Simba from The Lion King okay how
old were you I start dressing up at like
11 so I think I was Simba when I was
five okay so I did I didn't when did you
stop dressing up did you start dressing
up in high school or yeah I didn't
really dress up past eighth grade yeah
eighth grade was a year I went out and
threw eggs I think seventh grade I might
have wore masks
cuz you edged out of the costume into
the mask yeah you go from the costume to
the mask and then some people get into
the costumes again or get real creative
or whatever you know yeah um but seventh
grade is the year of like I'm gonna wear
a mask of a badass but you still like
candy you know you still want candy and
uh and then and then eighth grade is
kind of the year and then high school
you know some people have parties but
then high school Halloween I'm trying to
remember I think they were just oh [ __ ]
you know high school had a Halloween
like I can't remember one year I think I
went out with a bunch of kids we would
like to in similar [ __ ] me and my
friends in eleventh grade used to my
friend had a house in Rockville Center
and we used to throw fruit off which is
very dangerous to throw like fruit at
cars
there was like police and violet was
very bad it was crazy
like we threw whole fruit at cars
because we thought it was funny uh and
we were in 11th grade we're like adults
and we thought it was funny to just Pelt
passing cars with fruit and you know
they would get mad they would stop their
car there bang on my friend's door and
they would be like hey a [ __ ] I just
got nailed
like what the [ __ ] did like oranges and
just yeah whatever
you know people get pissed off at that
but this was like one of my one of your
your friends that you have where you're
like oh this kid's got a bigger house
than me
it's fun to hang out with uhm he's a fun
kid his name is Ryan still he's so full
of fun kid but like he would do crazy
[ __ ] he was really into pranks he was
really like so what they just loved it
they just love throwing like I didn't
give that much of a [ __ ] about pranks
but you just do what other people do to
fit in okay tech kids if you're
listening the biggest mistake you could
do is is march to the beat of your own
drum if someone else is doing something
even if it's dangerous just do it it's
the way the world works
that's how we get people to go to war so
my point is and if you tell me that you
shouldn't do bad stuff that other people
are doing don't ever tell me then how
are you gonna support the troops I think
that's pretty much the logic of that
well why are we all doing this thing
shut up and do it are these people
guilty of anything
shut up we're doing it okay I'm kidding
I know that there's more going on there
than that but III can't unpack it now
it's not the time it's not the time
always for discourse in geopolitics not
the time Safari n but sometimes you make
a friend you just got to do what they do
and this kid loved throwing eggs one
time me and him our other friend Tim who
passed away from drug overdose who's a
great kid very funny kid insanely funny
some of the first times I ever got drunk
were with this kid we would just show up
to his house hammered his mother would
be like what the [ __ ] is wrong with both
of you you're drunk
and he would be like you'd be like they
already took our fake IDs mom and she
would be like excuse me he's like we
were already caught this is overkill now
what you're doing is overkill and she
would just lose her mind and we would
feel that laughing he'd be like they
took our IDs
Gillian's mom which was like a Gillian's
was like I'm trying to think of the
plates like uh dave & buster's yeah
Long Island he's the gay took our IDs at
Gillian's cuz real IDs from Boston
College and they said then the guy said
he went to Boston College what dorm did
you staying in Tim said the Kennedy dorm
like an idiot I'm like maybe there is a
Kennedy doorman Tim's like but they just
knew that we were fighting his name is
Tim too and we also had a lot of fun my
friend Jerry Ann would pick us up a lot
and drive us places and she would be
like I don't know if we should do this
and Tim would just look Tim would look
at her go will you shut up like she just
drove 45 minutes to pick us up she's
like I don't know I think I had to be
home early he'd go hey shut up that's
the funniest thing ever the funniest
thing ever is to look at someone who's
genuinely like trying to have a moment
with you go hey shut up it was great he
did all that we let I mean made me laugh
so much and we one day we just bought
like three dozen eggs
there was a Bally's in his town cope egg
and and and the Bally's had a huge
window and the window was from floor to
ceiling and you saw all these people
like on the ellipticals or on treadmills
or whatever lifting weights uh we said
wouldn't it be funny if we just started
pelting the window of this Bally's with
eggs and we did it and no one cared like
no one really we'd like did in a bunch
people like barely noticing I was like
that we just ran away
we was just dumb things to do we're in
eleventh grade and have a lot to do you
know we threw things at people and then
we got into drinking and they were like
oh this is more fun that and there was
like a divide in our group because one
of the kids was like clearly not ready
to start drinking and doing other stuff
and he just still wanted to throw fruit
at things we're like dude we can't do
that forever like we have to sneak into
bars get drunk we have to throw up we
have to make out with checks like that I
remember one day we snuck into this bar
and it's not getting meaning that we had
fake IDs we were not you know we
wouldn't sneak in we're let in there are
these bars by Hofstra College in Long
Island and they're all underage and a
lot of
school people would go there literally
it's children it's like we open the door
and it's just like toddlers hammered
like dancing around and they get shut
down like all the time and they just pay
a lot of money for a fine and they
reopen his like another names they
reopen and there was one called Bogaerts
Bogaerts was this bar Club was a club we
would go in and do shots and I remember
I was like dancing with this girl one
less short hair she was like probably
like some like older Daiki or chick but
she was kind of hot and my friends older
brother just whispered in my ear as a
dance he was there he's like you're the
[ __ ] man and I was just like yeah I
felt so cool he was like you're the
[ __ ] man I was just dancing with this
like shorten it lesbian then we started
making out which was fine I didn't care
cuz I was like hammered and it looked
cool in front of your friends you know
it was just funny that we all got in the
car and then we had to pull over on the
way home we're all just vomiting and
what was funny is like when your
friend's parents didn't care like when
you get home and the mom would always be
like this is enough and the daddy be
like keep being kids they're just having
fun will you relax
and you know listen we're all successful
in our own right we're all fine I do
miss Tim who passed away he was a
[ __ ] very truly funny kid oh he's a
hot girlfriend always he was a surfer
skater kid always at a hot girlfriend
very very hot girlfriend and he was just
a very funny guy and that was one of my
favorite things ever did he would go
will you shut up
his mom would say something you'd go hey
Shh flip out you shut up like guys we're
walking to the car speak dope now I said
home by 12 you shut up you shut up
please shut up shut up shut up that I'm
I remember uh used to have a block party
was like a truly shitty block party on
his block and it was just like you know
just excuse for people to walk out and
drink in the street and like
he would always just like his parents
weren't even big drinkers but he would
make them feel like they were huge
drinkers he'd like walk out to the lake
his mom and Daddy be like that you're
gonna have a few more huh that's what
you're all about aren't ya
you're just got are you gonna call out
of work tomorrow you're just gonna what
how many beers you had 18 God we won't
see you for three months apparently what
are you talking about
they were like good parents like what
are you saying he's like I'm just saying
you know just take a few more and then
just get in the car go for a spin don't
worry it's just the law he's crazy so
funny dude there are those people that
you're blessed with in your life for not
that long who are so [ __ ] genuinely
funny none of whom are comedians that
I've met um but maybe that'll change one
day but it certainly hasn't certainly
hasn't come down the flappy hour are you
high I walk in and I go listen I she
calls my name for the mic I go I can't
go now
she goes why I said I I'm dressing up
like Jeffrey Epstein's temple and I'm
going to perform as that just like would
I'm like will you just call someone else
to this stage and give me a minute to
put on this box
I'm checking uh where the videos are
with you uh the video is out right now
hope post Malone retweeted 123 Ben it's
not that bad
I've been using Ridge wallet and I love
it I love it because I've learned how to
really cut down on a lot of crap I have
a few credit cards a debit card I have
my attorneys number just in case you
mean better filming somewhere and they
throw us in jail and take the camera
I love orig wallet I love simplicity
orig wallet is really a good thing try
it out folks easy it's a minimal front
pocket wallet it's designed to
streamline what you carry everyday it's
got 30,000 five-star reviews and is a
better way to carry your cash and cards
than a wallet where you open it up and
everything's falling out okay I'm tell
you everybody loves orig wallet there's
a lifetime warranty if you love it and
free returns if you don't that's how
confident they are that you're gonna
[ __ ] like it it comes in titanium
carbon fiber aluminum and over a dozen
different styles and colors okay it's
great Ridge wallet okay go to Ridge comm
slash Tim use promo code t I am for 10%
off your order this is a great present
for somebody a birthday somebody at work
somebody that you know it's a fun
president's not super personal so it's
just a nice thing hey man I got this
maybe you like it you know it's a good
gift for a dude who maybe wants to give
again for another dude and it's not like
the type of gear for it's like should we
suck each other off now it's just a nice
relaxed gift unless you want to suck
each other off and that's also fun and
nobody nothing in the rich wallets not
gonna get in the way of that because
it's a slim front pocket wallet II could
slip right in so if you're gonna blow
your friend Ridge wallet she's not
getting away of it it's not one of those
big wallets will make your dick look
small okay so that's another benefit of
the ridge the ridge wallet
sounds like a uh it sounds like a like a
white supremacist compound stronghold
like you come on down to the ridge come
on down and a ridge and hear the truth
that's what it sounds like but that's
not what it is it's actually a metal
wallet and it's fun okay I love it I
love the ridge wallet I love having a
wallet that doesn't impede my ability to
stretch do yoga you know I do a lot of
yoga in the airport you know a lot of
people see me in stretchy jeans doing
doing a yoga and I like it I have a
ridge there because it doesn't impact my
ability to do a nice yoga to do a yoga
you do any yoga Ridge comm slash Tim
used Tim TI m for 10% of your order you
like to show you want to support the
show get the [ __ ] ridge wallet
because that helps us it's a good
many people like it are you better than
them I think not
you don't need an old leather wallet
boomer
get a Ridge it's sleek and sexy it's
metal you can you could slice someone
with it if you need to it's a weapon
it's a wallet and a weapon you know you
know I'm telling you the ridge wallet is
essential for the modern man or woman or
woman you better buy these women
I want all women with ridges now I want
non-binary people gender non-conforming
I want all of you to have Ridge wallets
it the Ridge wallet doesn't have a
gender it's a little metal thing it
could be for anyone it's not masculine
or feminine it's just there it's just
like you know it's metallic it's an
element the carven Ridge is my favorite
what's your favorite Ridge my favorite
Ridge yeah the one I have which was that
this guy right here a pocket wallet
dummy oh I put it in my back on accident
this one it's such a cool color I put it
in the YouTube video you can see the
picture of it it's like blue on the top
and it goes down to the gray I love it
you're like a real mall skank anyway get
the ridge wallet it is a cool thing
actually I do like it listen I have the
carbon one
I like the carbon one ridge is the
future of wallets they have great
backpacks can people also get the
backpack I think so I have one of the
backpacks I love I love the backpack too
I don't know if people I don't know if
they sell the backpacks I would imagine
they do yeah get the wallet first that's
more important but listen also checking
in the backpack they make a really solid
backpack you know truly tremendous
backpack I'm all about Ridge come on
down to the ridge
my wife will make you meal and we'll sit
down and tell you the truth and then you
decide what you're gonna do about it the
region like we're watching the ridge
we've been watching them for six months
it's been intensity of activity a flurry
of activity up at the ridge or it sounds
like some what's that dumb show on
Netflix and everybody loves the ranch
the ranch with Ashton Kutcher
the ranch god help us god help this
country is it good I haven't watched it
I don't like it yeah it's a sitcom
that's Sam Elia and Ashton Kutcher and
he's the dad and they're married and
they listen I'll do that I'll do it as
much as I criticize all this [ __ ] I will
be in any of it because there is no God
and we're all gonna burn in hell Ridge
wallets Ridge comm / Tim 10% off your
order
TI m don't [ __ ] around get the ridge 5 -
what an hour we're at 55 right now yeah
yeah yeah I'm just giving you a time
stamp do six hours I'm deciding beside
he might have to fight the problem with
flying back to New York is that you lose
three hours and I hate [ __ ] up like
my sleep cycle I hate like taking a
red-eye where I don't sleep in the night
after in the day and then I can't go to
bed at night and I'm [ __ ]
I hate red eyes red eyes driving me
insane I don't like them they make me
paranoid I don't like being on a plane
where everyone's asleep at me I don't
like it so Stan I sometimes leave early
in the morning but then sometimes you
leave so early in the [ __ ] morning
that it's absurd I still may book 2 6 am
flight I don't know I gotta go I gotta
get a dress shirt for this [ __ ]
wedding and I got to get khaki pants or
like nice pants a dress shirt for the
wedding I actually don't have to do you
know I thought about I'm like I don't
really have to do laundry before I get
back on Sunday I'm just gonna buy an
outfit and wear it sex right yeah I
don't I can just do it on Sunday perfect
I don't have to go crazy I don't have to
go I just have to go to this wedding
where I'm gonna give somebody who makes
millions and millions and millions of
dollars a four hundred dollar gift
certificate to a restaurant and a bottle
of wine that I'm splitting with another
it's a group it's a group gift okay but
that's the way it is you gotta you gotta
act appropriately they say in a Long
Island wedding this is upstate
Westchester these people know how to act
this is gonna be nice I'm expecting some
good food
it's very nice food you know I mean
that's the situation you got a wedding
coming up that'll be have you guys done
any planning for it or you just it's
kind of yeah we we have the venue and
everything but we're working on
everything else right yeah you could
have a DJ you gonna have a band I'm not
sure yet you want me to get post Malone
he's good man he's talented I like him
what are you saying I like him like I
don't like I like him too
he's good want me to get Billy yeah can
you get Billy to come to my wedding I'm
a bad guy do-do-do-do-do-do-do people in
Long Island are so out of it they
wouldn't even know she is who's this
girl
oh this Sox put on y'all
where's Nelly they're like like 13 years
behind popular culture like Nelly
[Laughter]
where's Kanye West we love God they love
Kanye now she's talking about Trump in
Jesus nice it's a real it's a really
interesting thing watching people commit
their lives to each other is an amazing
thing I have friends with children
that's an amazing thing I encourage
people to do that to have children to
get married I think that's the way to do
it I think those experiences matter and
I think that we kind of devalue those
experiences and we tell everybody to
follow their like passion or their dream
knowing full well that most people don't
have a dream they're they have dreams at
night but they don't really have a
passion and a few people that have the
passion don't really have the work ethic
or the ability to do anything with it
so we've had this massive switch in
society where we're now just telling
everybody that they shouldn't have like
a stable career they should have an
exciting one and they should just be
excited because that's what Gary found
your Chuck said Gary Vee told me to be
excited every day and you know and
listen I get it listen I get that it
sucks being in a dead-end job I get that
you want to push yourself and you want
to you want to do something that you
love good you should you should do that
but the lack of honesty in society about
what that takes I don't feel like I
don't feel like it's ever been higher or
like it's at a fever pitch now the
dishonesty and the lying to children
about what it takes to follow a dream or
a passion we're completely denying
reality and we're telling children to
follow your heart follow your dreams and
being and that's why we have a
generation of people that are completely
unprepared when the door is shut in
their face continually and repeatedly
and they can't handle rejection and then
they flip out and they don't know why
they were rejected and they start saying
well it's society it's this it's not
it's these barriers it was a it's the
way it is it's the rule and not the
exception that people gonna tell you to
[ __ ] yourself over and over again we
seem to leave that out all the stories
seem to leave that out you know every
[ __ ] Rudy esque movie and it's about
somebody that dumb movie whiplash or
miles tellers that gets in a car
accident then he's just beating the drum
you know that's that's you know is that
what you want to be I'll just tell you
there's there's never been a time that I
feel like there's more of a disconnect
between the reality of what that process
is doing something on your own and the
idea of what that process is
and how you know glorified that process
is by people that tend to make money off
their commodifying your hopes and dreams
and they're making money telling you to
follow your dreams and they don't have a
goddamn clue what your hopes and dreams
are your hopes and dreams might be an
ethnos state they might be another
epstein island who knows but these
people are just here to tell you to just
go and do it just do it and get it done
[ __ ] it up it's your time to crush it
maybe maybe it is maybe they it's a
mixed bag
that's a Tim Dylan motivational course
you can follow your dreams but baby it's
a mixed bag and I'm telling you that as
somebody who things are working out it's
a mixed bag you got to make a few
sacrifices you got it like you know it's
not always gonna be what you think it's
gonna be and you don't you know you have
to kind of put a few things on the back
burner to do what you want to do and
nobody tells you that everybody tells
you have fun it's gonna be it's just you
know go get the glory bro it's gonna be
great you know it's not necessarily
great there's a lot of people I know
that got stable jobs that are very happy
with stable jobs and insurance and
they're able to have things on the side
and they don't need to earn money doing
the thing they love they can just simply
do the thing they love that's it that we
don't talk about that anymore in society
it's all or nothing in this society so
are nothing we don't like any moderation
so it's like go all the way or [ __ ] you
it's like that's not always the case
there's a lot of people that have
hobbies that are a great part of their
life that they don't need to earn money
doing you know most people do in comedy
it's a hobby for them they don't know
that it's a hobby because they're insane
but it's
hoppy they earn no money doing it here
comes the fire here comes the fire
trucks that nobody lets pass now it's an
ambulance
I was driving today and Oh God
here we go they go so slow these [ __ ]
people rush is supposed to be saving
somebody's life but it's somebody got an
eggshell in their eye but you know I was
driving today up in through Beverly
Hills and then like the fire trucks were
coming behind us these people don't even
want to let the fire guy they don't want
to even let the fire truck through you
know cuz they're late they're late for
table read from mom they want to hear
they want to do that when they need to
be at their table read for the new show
mom about a zany mommy
she's the zany mommy how about a show
called Nazi mom where Mama's red pills
wouldn't that be a great show Mama's red
pill and the family now has to deal with
it and the dad is like what's going on
everybody thinks it's always like men
that are red pill what if mom has red
pills and everybody's trying to pull her
back and she's drifting further and
further
does that not excite anyone that excites
the [ __ ] out of me that excites the [ __ ]
out I never really wanted to be in a
writers room I'll tell you right now if
if they do a show called red pill mom I
will write for that show you know we're
like the family sits down for dinner
okay
and she's just sitting there and she
serves everyone like roasted chicken or
maybe like salmon gravlax you know and
they're like why are we eating this and
she's like well you don't really know
much about your Nordic heritage but I
think we should start talking a little
more about who we are and where we come
from it starts like that like if people
are like okay like that's fine right and
then progressively through the first
episode she starts letting like letting
you in on the fact that she's a little
based as the kids say as the new
generation of children say it's gonna be
a fun world in 20 years I'll tell you
that much
if the kids are any clue it's gonna be a
fun world you may want the corporations
in 20 years you may be begging for chase
back you might be like remember when it
was just Citibank that we had to contend
with and not bands of marauding
Psychopaths that are armed to the teeth
I don't know if that's the case but it
certainly doesn't seem that thank God no
one leaves their home that's the only
thing that we all we all can really just
[ __ ] in the fact and the and the and the
comfort that nobody really unless they
have to
leaves their home we've created such a
life for ourselves online that we would
never be able to produce an actual life
online everyone's a hero and everyone's
this and that and in real life
everyone's just online at Dunkin Donuts
and disgusting but online everybody's
making positive changes their lives it's
a real it's a it's one motivational
poster online everyone's like an eagle
with the wings spread everyone's like
soar I'm soaring I'm I'm destroying
people I'm clapping back at the
president I'm [ __ ] on the president
I'm giving celebrities a piece of my
mind and then when you walk out of your
house what do you do you go to
McDonald's and you get a cheeseburger
and then you eat it in your car and you
cry and then you go back in and you're
like I'm gonna tell Alyssa Milano to
[ __ ] off and good cuz I don't like her
but that's what it is
so whenever whenever I think things are
gonna get too bad I realize that we are
blessed with the fact that but you know
who knows that'll eventually run out I'm
sure and as things get worse people
might you know people might venture
outside
I don't know may happen may not I just
want to go I just want to go to as many
weddings before that day happens I just
want to go to weddings that's all I want
to do man let's just go to weddings
somebody did somebody was oj oj simpson
did a Halloween thing I love him can we
forgive him can we let him back in like
can he come back now he paid his due he
killed his wife and a waiter and but
look at all the good things he's done
like I'm sick of this cancel culture not
taking into account the full person and
that's what I think Oh Jay is a real I
view him as a the first casualty of
canceled culture really we canceled him
we didn't take stock and he was like
great athlete a lot of good films fun
guy you know and he's cancelled people
got mad at Michael che for making a joke
on SNL this is the black portion of the
show I just go over black issues I'm
kidding but I just as I transitioned I
realized that that sounded crazy I just
don't have more to I don't really have a
lot more to say on OJ I well I say some
stuff about I have a whole bit about how
Jays the only motivational speaker that
anyone should listen to Oh Jane Trump
they both exemplify America but che said
something about Bruce Jenner he said
there was a fella named Bruce Jenner and
people said that's dead naming a trans
woman because Caitlyn is now Caitlyn and
my whole thing is well he said was there
was a fellow named he didn't say Caitlyn
was Bruce he said there was like past
tense which there was Bruce Jenner
existed he got married he had children
he won Olympic gold medals I mean to say
that Bruce Jenner was never Bruce Jenner
you could say that he didn't feel like
Bruce Jenner okay you can't say he
wasn't ever the thing but I think people
and then some people are like oh it was
just a cheap shot but you might have
been SNL's trash chase really funny but
Nelson ELLs garbage just not good and I
defended SNL I defended it to open mic
or [ __ ] on it and I feel bad that I
do that because the people who often
[ __ ] on SNL are often unemployable
vagrants who live on floors and borrowed
drugs so they are like [ __ ] on a
thing that they could be if somebody
gave them a job that they couldn't do it
because they would have to shower and
leave their apartment and arrive by like
9:00 like that would never happen never
hopped a couldn't even do it but but
they blame all it but SNL does here's
where those human you know like human
garbage people are right is that the
show is not good it's not funny
it has funny moments it's an hour and a
half it doesn't have as many funny
moments as a chart but like everything
else has passed its prime you know this
guy wrote us a thing about Peter Lugar's
and it all is it's still good it's all
old it's over it's got nothing to prove
anymore the heyday is it's already in
the history books nothing matters Peter
Lugar's is well past its prime it's well
past any type of the market isn't
checking Peter lubbers gonna be full no
matter what you say about it as Sanel is
just gonna be the show on 11:30
Saturdays on NBC really no matter what
happens until until they decide that
it's not gonna be that's what it is I
mean things get so big they become its
mythos Peter Lugar's has you know things
like that they just coast along you know
not being particularly impressive for a
while and then having hits here and
there Lugar's are certainly still a
great restaurant and SNL could still put
out a funny sketch but it doesn't mean
that on the whole on average these are
institutions that are well past their
prime and I'm always amazed that
everybody's shocked that it you know 150
year old Steakhouse
or a show that's been on 40 or 50 years
is no longer hitting like it used to be
yeah The Simpsons not hitting like he
used to be
get over it your childhood is over your
childhood is done we're moving on to
other things
stop remaking mad about you what the
[ __ ] is that you know they're gonna ruin
if I thought they weren't gonna ruin
we're you know nine one one would love
to see him get remade because I loved
that show I guarantee they'll ruin it
they're gonna ruin it they're gonna
introduce it to a whole new generation
of people as something that is much
shittier than the [ __ ] irreverent
hilarious thing that it was back when no
one gave a [ __ ] you know I you know talk
about political correctness I flat
myself it's so funny so some of the
Halloween decorations in Burbank and
some of them were a little weird there
were skeletons being lynched on the
trees and I just say to myself I go you
know me guys I'm not an SJ Dubbs but you
start seeing the skeletons being lynched
you go you know do we need that do we
need the lynched skeletons from the tree
now I know that lynching you know
lynching as a racial component
historically in this country no but
those white people that will it yet and
I know that I'm just saying do we need
it do we need the lynched skeletons for
the Halloween display for the children
you got two year olds and Buzz Lightyear
costumes pointing at these things what's
that oh that's a way to kill someone
where we hang them and we cut off the
flow there and a lot of times their neck
is broken before they can even die of
strangulation
anyway go and get your peanut butter cup
okay pal
oh no if we need that it was also like
there was one that was clearly an ode to
like what's the one was at Michael Myers
what's the one with the summer camp that
happens at the summer camp
Friday the 13th so there was clearly no
to that yeah they're all the same to me
it's there's Freddy Krueger there's
named Aaron Allen Street that is Friday
the 13th
than Jason it's all thing it blends
together in my head you know mm-hmm you
know I love all that stuff but I'm not
an aficionado I prefer horror movies
like um like things that I've seen that
have like you know Jacob's Ladder with
Tim Robbins which was a good one
things like cabin in the woods that were
fun you know Joss Whedon made you know
before he you know join the Lilith Fair
or whatever he thinks yeah that guy the
hell's going on here you got his wife
cancel them got Cannes was it cheating
on his wife he's that Kuwait you know
you don't know I love these guys it
could that get caught in and move like
further to the left when they were to
the left it's like no you got to go
right now
you got a shimmy ride shimmy ride Shem
who ride
you gotta get red pills you can't you
can't dance further to the left like
these guys these guys like they get
caught cheating on their wife and
they're like well I'm not binary now
it's like no way no no no no no no hold
on but that was a fun movie that was I
like a house of a thousand Corpses Rob
Zombie Devil's Reed Jack's I like stuff
that's a little campy a little funny it
has elements of fun in it but I love all
the old [ __ ] - you know hostel was fun
the ring was great
Jenny Slade's new special a lot of these
things are in and of themselves kidding
it's it's phenomenal you know
everything's great everything's great
the comedy press has lost their minds
now they've collectively lost their
minds where I can't even get mad at them
anymore
they should be put in a padded room
people writing about comedy right now
should be put in a padded room and and
have all sharp objects and shoe laces
taken away from them they are a danger
to themselves and others they are no
longer rational beings that should be
able to plan their own day they need to
be in an institution - sweet immediately
making comedy lists with people
comedy in five years who are homeless
and they're going to use people or the
comedians that you're gonna know
alright BAE by the way being on one of
those lists is a curse I know I've seen
people that have been on those industry
lists three years later they like
wandering around the streets of Los
Angeles
yeah like like they can't find their way
home so good luck and there's some
people that are funny to get on the list
but by and large every special review
every list right now is being made by
people who are mentally unwell
the only comics they like are comics
that they think would invite them to a
party
ie losers the only comics they like are
comics that don't remind them of the
people who rightfully used to spit in
their faces during homeroom I'm really
going off today you know it's so good
the airs are crisp and I feel very I
feel very good but but what I mean is
and I don't want to sound too drastic or
too extreme I believe the police should
arrest the people that are reviewing
comedy right now they should arrest them
in the middle of the night and take them
away from their families and interrogate
them with any as to why they find
certain things funny they should be
interrogating they should be under a hot
light and they should be forced to watch
this special and [ __ ] admit or at
least have reasoning for why you found
this funny whatever special happens to
be
I've got no beef with Jenny slain it's
just that was this special that
everybody said is the greatest thing
that's ever happened and I watched it
listen she's clearly talented it really
wasn't for me that's okay I'm probably
not for her but the praise that is
leveled on people clearly has nothing to
do with the actual thing anymore it's
completely divorced from what the thing
is it just doesn't matter it's not that
specific special it's really all of them
it's anything that's anything that
anybody's [ __ ] doing right now it's a
state and everybody's I'm making my
reviews a statement
it's it deserves nothing to do with the
actual thing did anybody's watching
nobody was mad about your pals special
it wasn't real these people turned it
into something that wasn't real okay
nobody thought Nanette was the greatest
thing in the world they turned it into
that no one not a one not a person on
earth was like this was the greatest
comedies but they might have thought it
was a meaningful piece of art but there
was not one people were trying to say it
is funny [ __ ] you you don't know what
it's like so my point is that the people
writing about comedy right now you know
and you know Jason cinnamon and the
times can write some good articles meg
rided vulture occasionally do something
that isn't completely insane sometimes
half accidentally Jesse David Fox is a
lunatic over whatever the [ __ ] he writes
for decider vulture whatever pretend
thing I'm just saying I'm not a little
I'm saying that these people should be
in jail do you understand what I'm
saying I can take criticism but I'm
saying it should be leveled at me from
bars that they are currently behind
that's that's my only point is that they
are not they're looking to kick up to us
and start trouble and stir the pot they
are not having real reactions to
people's comedy or art and they haven't
been for a while they are only trying to
start shed and the only comedy they like
is comedy done by people that they feel
crawl on their floor every night and a
ball of anxiety like these [ __ ] do
apparently and that's the type of comedy
that they like you know I have anxiety
to folks and a lot of my friends do too
I think Oh mass as anxiety you know but
the reality is they like one type of
comedy they think one type of car I mean
they write off skank fast as like this
[ __ ] it had the best comedians of the
last century their dummy
the exception of certainly some people
Louie Bill burr Bobby Kelly Bonnie
McFarlane yamaneika saunders rich vos um
[ __ ] Ron Bennington a legendary
broadcaster Dan Soder Marc Norman
Michael che
you know like Michelle wolf three years
ago they had like these are great cop
like you're writing it off is like this
alright thing is nothing to do with that
there's nothing to do it that were you
there were any of them there know that
no research no homework done nothing
they have no first-hand sources or
experience they source their articles
from other garbage that other people
tweet and Ryan but these people don't
contact anyone I've been contacted once
or twice by the New York Times guy and
he's actually he'd might do some due
diligence on some articles and I do
appreciate that but these people that
write about comedy should contact me
every week and I should write their
reviews for them I should go straight
every review that's what I'm saying I
should they should check in with me
every day hi Tim how are you what are
our orders
what should we do and then I give them
their orders I tell you what we're doing
this week that's what should happen
email me I write you your article or you
go to jail I don't feel like I'm being
unreasonable
[Laughter]
everybody's on Twitter trying to get
some goddamn attack these people you
know some people tell me they like the
videos and then they don't retweet them
I mean I'm gonna start asking people
let's say I like the videos I'm gonna
start looking at them straight in the
face dead in the face uncle can I ask
you why don't you retweet them are you a
coward is it moral cowardice what is it
is it that you don't feel like I do
enough for you
what do we
right now our 22 yeah we're gonna start
to wrap this out because we're after
then we'll record some algae some ads on
the road and we'll we'll we'll get this
baby to where it needs to be I wanted to
talk about a few more things it's been a
real uneventful Halloween I mean we made
a fun video we worked very hard on that
drove you know in LA people don't
realize you can only shoot because the
Sun trenches everything out it's very
hard to shoot you gotta shoot early
morning or like you know sunset time for
you know between five and six and to get
anywhere in the city is an hour and a
half an hour long traffic parkings a
[ __ ] I mean it is you know I love doing
it we have a lot of fun doing it but
it's actually it is a process it's not
nearly as easy to make things you know
when we're in Ben's garage it's a little
different but when we're going out and
actually doing something like this where
we got to go to several different
locations it's actually quite different
you know and it's kind of an interesting
it's very interesting to to do it and
then imagine that people do things like
that with a huge budget and they're out
there with so many professionals and so
many cameras and assistants and a huge
budget and they don't manage to ever do
anything funny even by accident and
you're like that's so shocking to me
that you people are so like divorced
from what is actually good that you have
all these resources at your disposal and
everything you do is [ __ ] over and over
and over again I it's like amazing to me
but that's the name of the game what it
is folks
you just gotta bury your head in in a
trough of [ __ ] for as long as you can
hopefully somebody taps you on the
shoulder one day and says hey hey it's
gonna be good you're gonna be okay keep
making those lists a third of the
comedians that you're gonna know
yeah is that it that the way it is okay
but if we don't know them in a year
the penalty for writing that article
should be death you should be put to
death because clearly there are no
consequences and the lack of
consequences are not good for anyone
you pseudo-intellectuals running around
there I I should be writing all of the
articles about comedy that's it that's
my offer and I'm offering anyone out
there some of them listen please I will
never take credit I will let you have
the credit and I will write the article
here's my first article here's my first
pitch okay okay the first call pitch is
called ten comedians who should be
killed in their homes and we write about
ten comedians who we make a list we go
from people who you wouldn't be upset if
they were killed in their homes two
people who should be killed in their
homes and that's the list and we do a
small paragraph on each picture to your
editors you know I mean here's another
article okay here's another article what
would you rather do watch The Tonight
Show or your mother get raped think
about it
beginning to end no commercials
beginning to end okay
and the guest is someone where Jimmy
can't really understand them because of
their quirky accent beginning to end
what what did you say Oh
or just a good old-fashioned rape of
your mother these are the thoughts these
are the questions these are the articles
it should be written these are the
talking points these are the issues of
the day
um we've had a lot of fun we're gonna
wrap it up we've had a lot of fun here
tonight folks I know that you want a
visual aid I we're gonna get back into
that studio but right now we've been all
over the place and because we're doing
these videos and because you know it's
getting a little colder out in LA it's a
little hard to be on that porch every
every time we're gonna still we'll get a
few more in and then we're gonna get
we're gonna go grab a studio and do it
like grown-ups because we can't sit out
on the porch your [ __ ] February and
we're not gonna sit there in the middle
of the day cuz the sun's gonna [ __ ] up
everything and you know you're not gonna
you're gonna barely see us so you know
we're gonna have Devin on again soon
everybody's running around we do
appreciate everybody that listens to the
show that tells their friends about the
show it donates to the patreon or they
you know just shares things on Instagram
and Twitter we do appreciate that you
know you guys are the ones that
determine who gets attention or what
what you know whose content gets gets
looked at [ __ ] everybody who's writing
about anything doesn't matter you guys
are the ones that matter so if you enjoy
what we do um you know keep keep keep
trying to share as much of it as you can
and you know we do appreciate it we're
gonna try to do cooler funnier stuff and
we're gonna try to keep getting better
we've got guests that are coming up on
on a lot of patreon episodes that I
think people are gonna dig and we're
gonna continue to have fun so let's you
know let's we'll arm ourselves let's get
ready I'm kidding but no let's um you
know let's really just here's a guy
driving by with a perfect ending guy
driving down the street
seemingly all of his possessions are on
the back of a bicycle I bet ya two years
ago he was on a list of comics that you
were gonna know you were gonna know him
you know nobody should have any
confidence people people in this
business should open the door every day
crack it open like there's someone there
coming to kill them
and that's the only way to truly advance
her like to truly appreciate how fragile
everyone's position is and how insane
this whole entire thing isn't how crazy
it all is and this boolean confidence
that people have is disgusting be
confident what you put out but don't
become you know this [ __ ] person like
you're a comedian you're supposed to be
making people laugh you're not a rock
star you're not a rapper calm down you
know enough cut it out your tongue tip
you love comedy calm for all your the
dates I'll be over cry sure a bunch this
week and then I'll be back in LA I will
be in Fort Worth Texas at hyena's the 14
to the 16th of November I will then be
at the Vermont comedy club the 20th
through the 23rd in Burlington the 5th
through the 7th I'll be at the stress
factory in Connecticut Bridgeport
Connecticut and then I believe the
comedy connection of Providence Rhode
Island the 14 to the 15th
yeah 13th and 14th 13th or 14th comedy
connection in Providence Rhode Island
January I'm gonna be at Magoo bees what
dates Magoo B January 9 through Saturday
the 11th January 9th a Saturday the 11th
Mugu bees in Baltimore Maryland timonium
ammonium yes Mon iam actually zany's in
Chicago I'm gonna be that there from
February 3rd through the 8th fifth of
the eighth fifth through the 8th and
then I just confirmed it all for today
I'm gonna be up in Toronto and the
Toronto dates it's a theater up there in
Toronto and it's going to be
it's gonna be a lot of fun February 14th
February 15th in Toronto then March 4th
Caroline's on Broadway New York City
first weekend headline and Caroline's
huge deal if you're in the New York area
and you could get down there it's gonna
be a great show I have a lot of fun I'm
gonna bring out some really fun openers
you guys are gonna dig it so that's all
the live stuff is more live stuff Tim
Jay Dylan di llo n on Instagram and
Twitter share this [ __ ] if you can we do
appreciate it and you know rate the
podcast review us 5 out 5 stars
leave as a positive review keep telling
your friends about it buy the products
if you need them even if you don't need
them the CBD helps us a lot
helps us if you buy these products you
know give it a shot if you hate it you
hate it give it a shot we're doing a
swipe up on my Instagram for new CBD
company that we're working with check it
out may be fun to try and all that stuff
does help the show and it helps fund all
the [ __ ] we're trying to do so thank you
very much I appreciate it
goodbye